no it's like i i i love you so much
that when i feel the way that kalila
must feel all the time being
it does make me angry because i'm like i
wish you could see
yourself the way i see you and like this
[ __ ] guy shows up to my house
and we're just doing a bobby lee fest
i'm like let's tell him yeah
let's just tell him like why are we
saying it to each other he should hear
this [ __ ]
and it really means a lot man
well you mean you mean a lot you changed
me you always do that you like you
changed my life dave i was in this
[ __ ] up place and i can't
you always say that but you changed me
and you know what that [ __ ] analogy
the lord of the ring things
i'm going to watch it tonight you know
when the hobbit's bowed to the king and
then the king
bows back to the hobbits oh word
i remember this did you see the iaea
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] your clicks
i cried i cried during that scene so i
bowed back to the hobbit
because you you you you i came on here
and he's like you're the king you're the
podcast
because you're gandalf and i was like i
bow to you the reason why that works is
because we
followed them from the first movie it's
just the movies were so
long and you know i mean and you know
what i mean and just painstakingly
difficult
that their voyage and just i needed that
you we follow you from mad tv
not a hobbit but i know yeah i get it
you know like yeah
all the things but you're right you're
writing all the harold and kumar [ __ ] oh
yeah you're right
you're right you're right starting the
podcast it's a long journey
yeah and uh and here's here then it
feels weird as
someone who's watched all the lord of
the bobby lee rings yeah yeah you've
watched your hobbit journey
yeah and then you get to the end and and
like we're bowing to you and you're like
um that was the same yeah and yeah
you're the [ __ ] king and then you're
like oh which one am i
which one am i you're you're um stan
white's kids man
i knew you were gonna say then you get
to the end and you're like oh uh i hope
they still like this
my hollywood pitch script and you're
like wait you you saved the planet
yeah you saved i think you would be mary
i think steven would be frodo right
i would be samwise no we in hobbits bro
like you're the hobbit
that hurts i'm sorry i turned that off
i i didn't even mean that but um i
apologize
i think i think it's not hobbit and
whatever
thing that they bring i think it's
you've always been a
a man of the people and i appreciate
that i'm like pissed that all right guys
steven union you know what you know what
i'm saying and i've been saying the same
[ __ ] he's been
[ __ ] saying this whole time and hear
from him but not me
i've i've been trying are you raising
your voice again because what that does
is i have a defense i want to end if the
longer it goes i start thinking i'm like
wait i
why does he hear it from him but not for
me you don't get mad at steve yoon but
why are you getting mad at me
he said the same [ __ ] i'm saying like
and because he doesn't raise his voice
he has a way of doing it we're like it's
more of a professor
the way he's sitting like a professor
yeah yeah you're very like
aggro sometimes dude you're like a
volcano it's erupting i'm going to run
you know
when you see a volcano erupting you
don't get to see what's going on
you run away beautiful volcanoes
i've never seen one live me either but
yeah i imagine
yeah yeah but i've seen yeah yeah very
good points there's steve
um i don't want to bow anymore because
we did seven
are you sure you're okay with seven yeah
i'm totally fine with eight you're one
away from the three i don't know
but i i want to i've cause the other day
yeah right
it took me a half an hour to get to bed
because i was
touching everything in the house three
times yeah and every i
tell him would hit my foot i would do it
three times and it took me like 30
minutes to get to bed and i touched
everything and i was like
i really want what are you doing you're
fine
um this is insane you're thriving
right so i'm not gonna do the three okay
i'm trying to break it
you you release yourself from that even
like cracks on the street like i wasn't
hungry and i was like
all right so play it out what would
happen what's gonna happen because in my
head i think i'm gonna die
like if i don't do like if i'm walking
down the